you're really not quite the contrary
how wrong could we possibly be hello
internet
welcome to film theory the show that
tells jokes that ooze with such ease but
those jokes are filled with such
cheese that the joke police might one
day raid my home and say
freeze the keyboard they'll seize the
lawsuits they'll tease and by now you're
all shouting stop
please today we're talking about a dr
seuss classic the lorax the classic tale
of how a flourishing forest full of
truffula trees was reduced to a barren
wasteland when a businessman rolls into
town and exploits the trees for profit
it's a classic story about how something
beautiful that everyone love
can be ruined by greedy corporate
interest and what better way for
illumination entertainment
creator of the minion movies to teach
that very lesson to a new generation
than by taking the iconic story and
adding an extra
hour of run time now some people might
call this an unnecessary
cash grab that totally negates the
message of the original story
what were you expecting a butt at the
end of that sentence it totally negates
the original message of the story but
not nearly as much as the decision to
take the pro-environmentalist icon lorax
and use them to promote
a mazda suv not hybrid or electric or
anything like that just a gas guzzling
suv and also hp
printers and ihop and freaking comcast
you see this this right here it's called
the point illumination entertainment
you missed it but see they're not alone
because when it comes to the lorax movie
audiences missed the point too and to be
clear i'm talking about that movie
itself and
all of the stuff that was shoved into it
to stretch that 30 minute story into 85
minutes of run time the lorax film
seems to have a message that's pro-tree
ending with a big musical about how we
all need to let it grow but if you
really look at what's
actually happening in this movie neither
the once-ler
nor the new villain aloysius oh hey
are to blame and yes i sang it's the way
i remember how to pronounce his name
every song in this movie is a bop movie
itself yeah
questionable quality but man the songs
are just delightful obnoxious for
everyone involved
unclear anyway the villains of this
movie aren't the villains here
rejoice all you once slur and greedler
shippers
how ba can they be not as bad as you
might think you see
meanwhile the characters that the movie
is trying to cast in the role of heroes
aren't quite as heroic as they might
seem the long and short of it all is
that no one
understood this story which is just a
wee bit concerning since in a very
literal way the fate of the world
depends upon its message
for starters let's take a look at the
main villain of the story as you may or
may not know the classic story of the
lorax is about the once-ler an
enterprising businessman who chops down
all of the truffula trees to manufacture
these wildly popular garments called
these but in this new lorax movie that's
all in the past it's a story within a
story in the present day of the film
we're living in the aftermath of the
once-ler
there are zero trees and the one city
that we see
needville is a synthetic consumerist
mecca run by a new businessman who's
come to power
aloysius o'hare who built his empire on
selling bottled air
while mr o'hara officially is a
businessman he basically just runs the
works for place and he has his own
secret police that try to stop our main
character ted when he attempts to sneak
out of town
cenidevil is basically a corporatocracy
a word that sounds like it was made up
in a dr seuss book but nope
it's uh actually right here in the
dictionary because truth is more
ridiculous than fiction sometimes the
business model of o'hare's air company
we're told is that
bottled air is made in a factory which
manufactures plastic bottles
you gotta be kidding me you really think
people are stupid enough to buy this
our research shows that if you put
something in a plastic bottle
people will buy it of course there's an
obvious conflict of interest here the
factories that manufacture o'hare's
plastic bottles spew smog which in turn
drives more people to buy
bottled air the more smog in the sky
the more people will bomb but if you
take a closer look at what's going on
o'hare might not be the villain that the
movie sets him out to be
because as much as what i've described
sounds like a dystopia if you look at
the actual lives led by the people in
sneedville the movie actually tells us a
completely different story for starters
the most dystopian part of this might be
the idea that people are paying for air
it'd be pretty dang evil if o'hare
monopolized the most vital resource of
all and then locked it behind a paywall
forcing people to pay him if they want
to live but that's not what's happening
here
it's not as if everyone in this society
is spending their lives strapped to an
oxygen tank sure
some of them buy bottled air for their
homes but they can just go outside at
any point and breathe the air for free
in fact on the extended version of the
opening song that appears on the
soundtrack
o'hare straight up tells us this fact
something they can get for free and it's
not as if the air outside looks all that
polluted people are dancing and singing
in the streets without having any health
concerns they're not coughing they're
not struggling in any sort of way
compare that to what the town was like
before aloysius o'hare showed up you got
yourself a different story i wonder what
the next million dollar invention's
gonna be
yeah i wonder the air quality was so bad
that people
outside were indeed coughing and
wheezing
what i'm getting at is that though
people act as though this bottled air is
something that they need in order to
breathe the bottled air they buy
isn't really improving the quality of
the air that they have access to in
their homes or outside
it is pure placebo effect and we can
prove it using science take a closer
look at those bottled air machines
inside of people's homes we see that
they dispense air from bottles that are
similar to the standard water cooler
bottles which are around 5 gallons or 19
liters in capacity and
something about that should strike you
is off the average human breathes around
7 to 8 liters of air
every minute which is more than ten
thousand liters of air per day
meaning that if the citizens of the
needville were solely reliant on
o'hare's jugs of air they would run out
in mere
minutes sure they might get themselves
some psychological boost from thinking
that o'hare's air is breathing fresher
but it's just that it's psychology
not biology the fresh air that they're
buying from o'hare is no different from
the fresh air they'd get if they simply
opened up a window
wow it's kind of like another resource
we have in real life that's
available to us that many opt to pay for
because it comes in tiny plastic bottles
that claim to be fresher
go figure i'm talking about water here
guys thought the metaphor was obvious
enough but i feel like i need to spell
it out bottled water
o'hare's air is just the stand-in for
bottled water but one thing we
can say is that before o'hare the town
was a wasteland thanks in large part to
the once-ler cutting down trees in the
present day of the movie
needville is an artificially created
utopia where
everyone is happy where the air is
cleaner than anything that exists around
it we
saw how much of a wasteland it was
before o'hare and in the present day we
see ted cough on smog-filled air when he
leaves the city's walls
as ted gets further away from the city
the more air pollution there seems to be
if anything thineville is the one place
that seems to have escaped from this
fate
somehow by hooker by crook aloysius
o'hare managed to create what is
by all accounts a thriving city despite
the lack of trees he found a way to
allow people to breathe
free air even when they're not consuming
his bottled air if you look at it that
way o'hare
almost seems like a hero at the end of
the movie when we look out over the
ruined wasteland it's important to
understand
that isn't what o'hare created it's what
he had to
overcome for his company and town to be
successful
and he did it the people are happy as we
see in the opening song of the movie his
consumers are clearly thriving happy
about him
happy about the city they live in
welcoming his entrance and the city's
new parking lot in a grand chorus
in fact if you actually look at the
living conditions of people in
sneedville it seems
not bad at all for a movie that's
supposed to be all about the woes of
modernity and the harm brought by
capitalistic greed we don't see
anyone in sneedville that seems to be a
real victim of o'hare's enterprises
we don't see people who are left poor
and destitute we don't see people who
are forced to work jobs that they don't
like in order to keep up with the rat
race or worse yet in order to breathe
people happily prance around while
they're on the job and everyone seems to
have tons of time for leisure and enough
money to buy
giant cars the inciting incident of the
film where ted goes off in search of a
tree
isn't because someone is actually
suffering from a lack of trees it's
because he wants a kiss from audrey the
hot girl next door that he has a crush
on what i want more than
anything in the whole world is to see
a real living tree if a guy
somehow got you one well i'd probably
marry him on the spot
heck she's not even pining for nature
she doesn't want to see a forest she
just wants to see a tree in her backyard
for the funsies for the novelty of it
these are the concerns of the people of
the needville
it ain't too shabby so o'hare doesn't
really seem to be that much of a bad guy
here sure he doesn't want to grow the
tree at the end of the movie but outside
of that he took a desolate polluted
wasteland and turned it into a
consumerist utopia where everyone is
happy sure
he's rich but he's rich off of producing
a product that people were willing to
pay for
so if o'hara isn't the bad guy then
surely the bad guy is the one slur
i'm not bad i'm the good guy here looks
like someone's seen an episode of film
theory before but seriously it's hard to
defend this guy considering he's
definitely the one to blame for all the
trees being cut down
kind of i mean technically it was his
overbearing mother who pushed him to the
brink
see we're not making sneeds fast enough
we could always start
chopping down the trees man it is no
wonder that tumbler fell in love with
this guy he's a tall
thin guitar playing nerd who wears vests
loves marshmallows and has mommy issues
you always said i wouldn't amount to
anything remember oh hush your mouth
that was just trying to motivate you
i'm really glad that you clarified that
because it actually hurt my feelings for
a really long time but yeah at the end
of the day it's old onesie who's
responsible for chopping down the trees
which is bad
so thus he is the villain except we see
his backstory he sets off on his own to
make a business because he has a product
that he believes in
garbage oh no oh no
you do not get it this is a
revolutionary product
that will change the world as we know it
it is a million uses
and nobody believes in him nobody but
nobody's gonna buy that thing he goes to
town
every day for a week and just gets
harassed by the awful terrible people
there like it is brutal for just this
one guy in his guitar and a dream and
yet despite
all of this adversity he still keeps
trying and you know what it eventually
pays off
onceler wasn't wrong his product is
something that everyone wants
the thnead is the world world-changing
product that he thought it was i'm sorry
i just can't fault a hard-working guy
with a dream who overcomes adversity to
achieve tremendous success
as the bad guy in this case his one
fault and this
is a biggie is that he doesn't replace
the trees and that's not
evil it's just stupid and bad business
as he too quickly learns without trees
his business dies there's a reason why
in real life 80 to 90
of newly planted trees are planted by
logging and paper companies to quote
from one of their websites how would it
be in their best interest to destroy
forests with no intention of replacing
the trees that are used to make paper
sustainability of harvestable areas is
crucial to the long-term survival of any
paper company and that means that
sustainable
managed forests are crucial to their
business model the harvested areas for
paper companies are also known as
managed forests essentially detailed
models are built that allow trees to be
harvested sustainably for each tree
that's cut down
several are planted or naturally regrown
in its place
at a rate that keeps the environment
stable according to the u.s forest
service
over 4 million trees are planted in the
united states
every day with nearly 2 million planted
by the paper
and wood products industries remember mr
beast's team trees 20 million dollars
for 20 million trees
amazing accomplishment right and it was
but in perspective that's
five days worth of planting for these
companies
the businesses aren't evil or at the
very least aren't evil for those reasons
their business interests force them to
be sustainable
and that is the once-ler's big mistake
he didn't see the forest for the trees
if you'll pardon the pun so who is the
villain of the lorax
it's the consumer it's us it's easy to
point at the big business guys
in this case the once-ler and aloysius
o'hare and say you did this you're the
one at fault for all of this but
they're only doing what we as the
consumer are telling them to do
both o'hare and the once-ler reference
the consumer at various points
throughout the movie
you gotta be kidding me you really think
people are stupid enough to buy this
can we fold him for selling us a product
that we're telling him we want he
doesn't believe it but if that's what we
want
he'll sell it to us and again with the
once-ler how bad could i possibly be
all the customers are paying and the
money's multiplying
the customers are buying that is us
telling him we approve of what you're
doing keep providing
that service again both men are just
fulfilling a need that the consumer is
telling them that they want for more
proof
onceler was ready to pack up his need
business when it wasn't selling but
ramps it up again when consumer demand
is through the roof if it wasn't for all
of those people wanting to buyeth need
the forest would still be intact from
what we see
and hear in the movie the people of the
needville are perfectly happy with their
giant cars
and their inflatable trees and their
waste of batteries
they want those things and you know what
they don't want trees
stop it one slur and o'hare aren't the
bad guys like the movie wants to frame
it it's much more complicated than that
we're the bad guys here because we are
the ones that let their bad business
practices slide
we didn't prioritize nature we didn't
care about the trees because we wanted a
need no matter the cost we didn't care
about air quality to worry about
o'hare's pollution for change to happen
it doesn't fall on them it falls on us
and if we disapprove of the way someone
is doing business or what a company
stands for
it's up to the consumer to vote with
their dollar but to both o'hare and
once-ler in the movie the dollars thus
far had been telling him we approve what
you're doing
that's why this line in the movie and in
the book is so important
because unless someone like you cares a
whole awful lot
nothing is going to get better it's not
about the once-ler it's not about o'hare
it's about us
and that is the message of the lorax one
that i think most people
and especially illumination
entertainment completely missed but
hey that's just a theory a film
theory and thank you again for
supporting this channel
and for supporting today's sponsor
nordvpn
why use a vpn you ask well for one thing
a vpn encrypts your online life to
ensure that you stay
anonymous so whether you're banking
online or you know
trudging through the depths of the
once-ler fandom for research
obviously your information is gonna stay
protected and you
are gonna stay embarrassment free and
with nordvpn you actually get
double data encryption for increased
anonymity so absolutely no one will be
able to see your swaggler x weirdler
alternate universe fanfic from early
2014 that you are reading before
recording this video
not even you know your significant other
some things are just kept between you
and nord and best of all while you're
stand protected you're also staying
fast vpns usually get themselves a bad
rep because they'll often slow down your
internet but with nord you have
unlimited bandwidth which means that
you're not slowing down your upload and
download speeds which means that you
won't have any issues streaming the
lorax soundtrack on every device in your
home because
man that thing is catchy and i haven't
even mentioned the best part
using nord unlocks websites not
available in your part of the world
so let's just say you want to watch
every single iteration of the circle
on netflix cause you finish the us
version in one sitting and you're a
human being who lacks any semblance of
self-control well guess what you can do
exactly that the circle uk the circle
france the circle brazil
all of them await your binge-watching
pleasure all of it just two clicks away
using nord that's all just scratching
the surface if you like nordvpn you can
also easily integrate the service
nordpass their password management
service nordpass is great because it
allows me to finally ditch all my cringy
early internet passwords like 69
sephiroth lover 69
checkered belts forever and one two
three four password four three two one
all in favor of more age-appropriate
complicated and most importantly of all
secure passwords and best of all you
don't have to worry remembering them
because nordpass remembers them for you
while protecting them for a limited time
nord is offering a special black friday
deal
every purchase of a two year plan gets
you 68
off plus four additional months for free
all you have to do is go to nordvpn.com
film theory or use the code film theory
at checkout
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y
it is absolutely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee
and it's a great gift for the holidays
that's nordvpn.com
film theory get the black friday deal
before it ends
four months for free best of all you
aren't ruining the environment in the
process you can say it's lorax approved